it's really amazing i mean zabeet
nurmagomedov um you know you can
keep going down the line there's so many
of these guys that are coming up it's
really uh what a hotbed of talent
especially dagestan
i mean how many bad [ __ ] come
out of dagestan yeah
it's a b versus i mean um khabib versus
conor
like holy [ __ ] is that fight interesting
what the [ __ ] is going to happen
if it really happens you know you don't
think it's going to happen don't say
that
son of a [ __ ] look at him there who
i mean how weird is it looking at conor
with no belt
khabib with the belt i mean forever
khabib is trying to get a shot at that
belt
and the way he won it crazy [ __ ]
setting up this fight this fight is a
[ __ ] interesting fight man
because if conor can't stop that
takedown does he go the way of everybody
else does he get mauled the way
everybody else got mauled
does he get mauled the way michael
johnson got mauled does he get mauled
the way dosagnos dosanos got mauled
uh chandler oh not chandler uh johnson
michael johnson
yeah we said johnson um edson barboza
yeah he got mauled
the way barboza got mauled was scary
because like halfway into the first
round
khabib's taking him down and you see
barboza just taking a deep breath like
this like
like realized like oh no yeah like what
in the [ __ ] is all this about that's
worse than i imagined
yeah this is just a completely different
thing really i mean no doubt
conor probably has the heaviest hands
in the game no doubt but take down
defense
and fighting off your back that has
nothing to do with the power
it's not it doesn't translate and also
what is it going to look like is
his takedown defense better
than michael johnson's is his takedown
defense better than edson barboza or
ally quinto who's a wrestler
yeah i mean al stuffed his takedowns a
couple times in the first round
yeah but you know the persistence al's a
really good
wrestler yeah and how how good is
conor's
it's a good question man he what if he
gets
what if he gets tired what if he gets
taken down easier than all those other
guys
you don't know right you know what i
mean he's got dylan danis in his corner
dylan is uh i think he wrestled in high
school and
um i'm not too sure
he brought in uh some olympic caliber
wrestler for his camp
uh who did uh connor brought in some um
some
super high level wrestler for his camp
a famous one yeah james can't find it
a ufc fighter i don't believe he's ufc
fighter
say it again is it kyle snyder does it
say that says he offered to help him i
don't know if that's what he really
brought in i don't know who he brought
in
um but i know that there is some talk
about him bringing in some
super high level wrestling it says that
jordan burroughs is not working with
conor which is that might be who you're
talking about
could be well that would be one who you
would want to work
with you that would be someone who you
would get asked but jordan burroughs is
probably [ __ ] busy
and has he expressed an interest in
finding an mma
because if he does there's a lot of
people that are [ __ ] he tweeted out on
the 13th of august i'm not working with
connor i'm attempting to win a world
championship of my own in october
it doesn't say wrestling yeah it didn't
say yeah okay yeah so
yeah that's what i was thinking like he
probably doesn't have time to help
someone with a camp like that
especially like at this point in his you
know he's taken off right now
if he ever decides to go into mma like
yikes
yeah i wonder what's going to happen in
that fighter manager don't know whether
or not
khabib is going to be able to close the
distance without getting hit whether
conor's going to be able to stay on the
outside long enough where the khabib is
going to come at him like with reckless
abandon the way he did with edson
barboza
he just stormed after barboza just
walked him down yeah
is he going to be able to do that with
conor or is he going to get clip coming
in i mean
is he going to be able to to fade that
left hand is going to be able to stop
that
and if conor could just keep him from
taking him down a couple of times in the
first round
just a couple of times just enough to
put a little bit of doubt
get a little bit of that [ __ ] talking
going and land a couple of good punches
or does khabib just grab him early rag
doll
boom side control elbows punch
knee on belly punch punch punch elbow
punch
do we just see a mauling
it's interesting you know it's it could
go either way like i see both
this this is one of those weird fights
where i don't know what the [ __ ] gonna
happen but i don't think we're gonna see
like some crazy drawn out five round
fight i definitely could be wrong
but i think we're gonna see like one
person
whether it's whoever figures out how to
impose their game whether it's conor can
dominate on the feed or khabib can
dominate on the ground
you think that'll be the biggest
pay-per-view ever it's going to be huge
it's going to be so big
it's going to be how could it not be the
biggest one it'll be giant
conor's the biggest star right the only
thing that's going to hold it back is
mainstream knowledge of it because
there's not a lot of press
because conor's not doing a lot of stuff
it's not like in the news a lot like how
many of these regular people
know that conor's gonna fight yeah and
you never see it on instagram
you know anything you see ufc pages
if you and i see it you and i see it we
follow mma pages but
[ __ ] man is khabib doing interviews is
he talking i have no idea
i don't know that means no man if you
don't know
yeah i don't know i mean [ __ ] i haven't
seen much i mean i've seen some video
footage of him training at aka
the whole thing's crazy man so so i mean
i'm just i'm crossing toes i'm crossing
everything just
please let this one go down please
i can't imagine someone getting injured
i'd be so i wouldn't mind if someone got
injured i'd be so sad well you wouldn't
because tony would jump in
the truth and it's still going to be a
great fight either way
either way the guaranteed there's going
to be some serious [ __ ] either tony
versus khabib
tony versus connor or conor versus
khabib i think tony is one of the more
dangerous fights for conor
because first of all his durability his
endurance is crazy
his ability to fight from anywhere he
can he fights real good standing up
he puts a pace on you doesn't mind
getting hit always walking
forward always walking forward and
walking people down if you hit him you
can hit him and hurt him doesn't matter
he survives he survives
finds a way to survive and one little
scramble clinch
on the ground and there's a dars right